Michael Jackson's legacy crumbles under
charges of pedophilia illegal
immigration surges and Democrats ignore
anti-semitism once again to cover for
the fresh faces I'm Ben Shapiro this is
the Ben Shapiro show
we have a lot to get to today we're
gonna jump right in in just a second
first let us talk about your rights when
the founders crafted the Constitution
the first thing they did was make sacred
the rights of the individual to share
ideas without limitation by government
the second right they numerated was the
right of the population to protect that
speech and their own person with force
you know how strongly I believe in these
principles I'm a gun owner owning a
rifle is an awesome responsibility
building rifles is no different Bravo
company manufacturing was started in a
garage by marine vet more than two
decades ago to build a
professional-grade product that meets
combat standards BCM believes the same
level of protection should be provided
to every American regardless of whether
they are a private citizen or a
professional BCM is not a sporting arms
company they design an engineer and
manufacture life-saving equipment and
they assume every rifle leaving their
shop will be used in a life-or-death
situation by a responsible citizen law
enforcement officer or a soldier
oversees every component of a BCM rifle
his hands assembled and tested by
Americans to a life-saving standard BCM
feels a moral responsibility as
Americans to provide tools that are not
going to fail the user when it's not
just a paper target but somebody coming
to do them harm to learn more about
Bravo company manufacturing head on over
to Bravo Company MFG comm that is Bravo
Company MFG comm if you need more
convincing
check them out also a youtube.com slash
Bravo Company USA that is Bravo Company
MFG comm go check out the folks making
the best rifles on the market that's
Bravo Company MFG dot-com all righty
well we have a lot to get to today in
terms of the news but there's been a
cultural shift that's been happening a
cultural moment that's been happening
surrounding Michael Jackson it's way
past due and it is testament to the
innate ability of human beings to cover
for people that they consider talented
there's something in psychology called
the halo effect the halo effect
essentially suggests that if you think
somebody is good at one thing it means
you think they are good at all things so
you tend to think that beautiful people
are smart you tend to think that people
who are smart at one thing are smart at
all the things we tend to think that
rich people know what they're doing when
it comes to everything and there's just
a normal human tendency we tend to make
snap judgments about people and then we
take those judgments to finally
generalize more broadly well Michael two
things are true of Michael Jackson
immensely talented human being evil
pedophile right those two things are
true of Michael Jackson at least if the
allegations are to be believed which all
evidence suggests they should be and
people are having a really tough time
connecting those two they're having a
really tough time overcoming the
cognitive dissonance of I like Michael
Jackson's music and I was a big fan of
his when I was 10 with Michael Jackson
was an evil human being who preyed upon
children now both of those things can be
true and this new documentary leaving
Neverland on HBO which I've been
watching is indeed extraordinarily
upsetting it is it demonstrates how
depraved Michael Jackson was there's a
piece a national review by Kyle Smith
talking about this he says debuting on
March 3rd and 4th after a previous
series of screening at the Sundance Film
Festival this enraging film by Dan Reid
inspired a lawsuit against the pay cable
channel from Jackson's estate which
desperately wants people not to see a
story that may significantly diminish
the value of his brand it's a wonder
there's any brand left to defend given
that four men have now made detailed
credible claims that Jackson sexually
abused them as minors over extended
periods of time
Jim's safe chuckled actor first met
Jackson at 9 while filming a famous 1988
Pepsi commercial in which his excitedly
examining Jackson's dressing room when
the singer pops in the commercial safe
Chuck says generally captured his first
glimpse of the celebrity around the same
time Wade Robson then v met Jackson
after putting on a dazzling performance
in a dance contest in Australia causing
the singer to bring the boy onstage for
concerts and invite him to show his
moves in front of a huge crowd on the
Australian tour wind town Jackson
invited the boy to look him up in LA
sometime driven by his mother joy the
family managed to make contact with
Jackson on vacation when the boy was 7
Jackson immediately invited the robeson
family to stay at his huge ranch at
Neverland Wade and his 10 year old
sister were allowed to sleep in
Jackson's room days later Jackson talked
the family into allowing way to stay
behind with him while the rest of the
family went to the Grand Canyon you and
I were brought together by God Robson
recalls Jackson saying we were meant to
be together and this is us showing each
other that we love each other this is
how we show our love Jackson then
fondled the boy and guided the child to
his own genitals and Jackson initiated
oral sex and guided the boy to follow
suit Robson recalls Jackson telling him
other people are ignorant and they're
stupid they never understand if they
ever found out what we were doing
we'd be pulled apart he and I would go
to jail for the rest of our lives
later at Jackson's coaxing after Jackson
called Wade every day for two years and
kept him on
phone for up to seven hours at a time
joy simply moved with Wade and her
daughter from Australia to SoCal leaving
her husband and other son behind a move
that ultimately destroyed the family
Wade's father would later commit suicide
safe trucks story follows a similar
pattern he recalls being lured quickly
into Jackson's bed at age 10 his
starstruck mother Stephanie was disarmed
by Jackson's childlike demeanor and
began thinking of the pop star as her
own son safe Chuck's memories of
Jackson's sexual abuse are familiar to
Robson's Jackson's staged a mock wedding
ceremony robeson recalls in which the
singer presented the boy with a ring
lined with diamonds he would reward me
with jewelry for doing sexual acts for
him you'll remember that in 1995 he
settled the civil suit for a reported 23
million dollars after being accused of
sexual abuse by jordan chandler who and
was arrested in 2003 again on charges of
serially molesting a thirteen-year-old
gavin a thirteen-year-old named Gavin
Arvizo a cancer stricken boy he had met
through a charity during his criminal
trial Jackson urged both safe Chuck and
Robson now adults to testify he had done
nothing inappropriate with them save
Chuck simply declined and in his silence
he incurred Jackson's wrath he
threatened me with my with his lawyers
and said I had perjured myself years ago
he recalls the lawyers would get me
he says Jackson told him at the same
time Robson recalls he was still
somewhat attached to Jackson he panicked
at the thought of the singer in prison
and what might happen to him there
perhaps Jackson would even be murdered
behind bars he thought so he lied
offering false testimony that Jackson
had not done anything sexual to him for
Gavin I wish I was a place where I could
tell the truth and be a comrade with him
Robson says now I just wasn't ready his
testimony and that of actor Macaulay
Culkin another man who'd spent a lot of
time with Jackson as a boy probably
swayed the jury he was acquitted on all
counts was Jackson in 2005 and died of
course in 2009 the the final 45 minutes
or so of the documentary does delve into
the depression and torments as well as
that of their mothers each of whom
searches her soul at excruciating link
well they're a bunch of lessons to be
learned here well some of those lessons
include again our capacity for cognitive
dissonance blinding us to the reality
about human beings
second the worship of celebrity that we
have in our society you know the rise of
a television and movie culture the rise
of an entertainment culture that puts
celebrities before our faces all the
time makes us think that we know
celebrities it used to be the people who
were very famous
felt distant and far-off now people who
are very famous feel very close to us
and
it's very difficult for us to believe
that those people could actually be evil
and participating in acts of evil that
that sort of stuff is is something that
we all ought to keep in mind whether we
are talking politics or entertainment
when we're engaging with the public
world that is deeply important for us to
recognize that human beings are still
human beings even if they are rich
powerful and famous and maybe even more
so then because rich because fame and
wealth and power these things allow
people to gratify their worst urges and
lead other people to basically give them
the OK to do so
thinking of course that the person
wouldn't be rich powerful and famous
unless they were also morally good now
this also has raised some serious issues
about pedophilia itself and it
demonstrates what we have lost as a
society when we decided that biological
urges on any level are incentive to are
basically an excuse to do what we want
we have a very weird divide in the in
the Western psyche right now when it
comes to biological urges on the one
hand we believe the biological urges
give us moral impetus to do the things
that we want to do so if you don't have
sex before marriage of a biological
impetus to have sex before marriage that
means it's okay to have sex before
marriage at the same time there are
obvious biological urges that people
don't want to give the go-ahead to
because they're in fact evil so if a man
has a biological urge to rape a woman
then we say no you're not allowed to do
that you are evil your biological urge
does not overcome and yet it's that
broad blanket statement that biological
urges are somehow an excuse that and the
Lady Gaga morality born this way is
somehow an excuse for behave this way
that's deeply troubling now again I'm
not comparing homosexuality to
pedophilia because they are completely
not the same thing one is a consenting
relationship between two adults and
another is the exploitation of a child
the point that I'm making is that as a
general rule a society that fails to
draw moral lines around things like
consent and instead draws moral lines
around things like biological drive or
biological urge as a society that is
going to fall apart at the seams and it
seems that we are moving in that
direction that we have failed to allow
morality to guide our views of personal
behavior and once we don't start setting
human limits to the biological urges
that we have we get ourselves into
very serious trouble the reason that I'm
bringing this up is there's a column
from Dalia with wick who is a legal
analyst very famous legal analyst
actually writing over at Slate comm in
which she has a piece called is
pedophilia a crime or an illness we've
never quite known whether child
molesters should be treated as sick
people or punished as criminals she says
on Sunday HBO premieres Finding
Neverland again and for all the wrong
reasons we can't take our eyes off
Michael Jackson whether or not the
allegations are substantiated the
question is in the air is pedophilia a
disease to be treated or a crime to be
punished our people who seduce minors
sick or evil our current legal and
medical systems blur both views we call
for the most draconian punishments life
imprisonment castration permanent exile
precisely because we view these acts as
morally heinous yet also driven by
uncontrollable biological urges if sex
with children is truly the product of
freely made moral decisions then we
should deal with it through the criminal
justice system but if it is genetically
over determined impulse an
uncontrollable urge nestled in our DNA
then punishing pedophiles must be
morally wrong this without Lilith
macwrite as science and culture
increasingly medicalized as bad behavior
finding a neurological component to
everything from alcoholism to youth
violence we run the parallel risks of
either absolving everyone for everything
or punishing criminals or no guilty er
than cancer patients what science has
revealed says left WIC about the moral
medical roots of pedophiles is of course
ambiguous what is clear is that the
binary choice laid out above is an
oversimplification the medical community
which started to view pedophilia as a
disease rather than a crime in the 19th
century has amassed evidence that at
least some violence and antisocial
behaviors have genetic links and
signposts a researchers have been unable
to isolate a biological cause for
pedophilia or even to agree on a
personality profile not to mention the
terrific confusion within the medical
community in defining what this disease
really involves until a few years ago
for example the DSM for the Psychiatric
Association's Diagnostic and Statistical
Manual of Mental Disorders defined
pedophilia as a disease only if the
sufferers fantasies sexual urges or
behaviors caused clinically significant
distress or impairment in social
occupational or other important areas of
functioning in other words it
non-impaired remorseless pedophile was
apparently perfectly healthy by the way
it is worth noting that is exactly the
same language that the dsm-5 now uses
with regard to transgenderism they
suggest that transgenderism
is not in fact a mental disorder unless
as clinically significant distress or
impairment so we what we have been doing
is medicalizing and again transgenderism
is not the same as pedophilia
transgenderism is an adult making a
decision presumably to behave in a
certain way that does not impact other
people in violation of their consent
pedophilia is of course the exploitation
of children I keep repeating this
because there going to be people who
don't understand the argument that I'm
making and seek to conflate all of these
things they are not the same and
homosexuality is not the same as
pedophilia is not the same as
transgenderism pedophilia is something
apart because it is morally evil because
it is morally evil but the point that
I'm making is that when we medicalize
evil then we also run into the danger of
suggesting that human behavior is not
controllable and that we are not
responsible for our actions and that is
the death of a civilization I'll talk
about that in just a second but first
folks I've had it with Congress the
folks in Congress right now they are
lunatics plus the executive branch is
growing out of control you know the
Constitution was designed to prevent the
federal government from taking all of
our freedom and from using that freedom
against us well the federal government
has overgrown all of its boundaries
which is why we need to restore the
original bargain of the Constitution the
checks and balances that were originally
established to prevent this sort of
domination of our freedom this is why
I'm a big believer in calling a
convention of states where we the people
can propose amendments yes amendments
we've got to stop these idiots before
it's too late the only way to do that is
to restore the greatest ideology ever
created the constitutional ideology of
the founding fathers can you imagine the
looks on the faces of the people in the
federal government when they realize
that their power has been restricted
calling a convention of states is the
only way to get the job done there are
already 3.8 million people with us on
this more every day so join me and my
friend mark mecklen go to convention of
states calm slash Ben and sign the
petition today that is convention of
states calm slash Ben they have
tremendous amounts of support
you should join them they're already 3.8
million people using convention of
states calm go check them out convention
of states calm slash Ben the reason that
I bring up the dahle liquid column is
because she suggests this dichotomy in
the dichotomy is basically correct she
says it's oversimplified but it really
is not it's basically right she suggests
that if sex with children is truly the
product of freely made moral choices we
should deal with it through the criminal
justice system if it is genetically over
determined impulse an uncontrollable
urge
then we can't punish pedophiles but here
is the point the belief in a free
functioning free society has to be that
reasonable human beings have the
capacity to overcome their biological
instincts that human beings have the
capacity to overcome their tribal
affinities that human beings have the
capacity to overcome their urges if we
don't believe that we cannot have a
republic and here is where psychology
shades into politics we are now living
in a in a world in which we are told
that we don't control our own behavior
that our behavior is controlled by
impersonal forces far beyond us that
there is institutional racism sexism
bigotry homophobia that controls your
life that it is the broad-based
economics of the of the American system
that have determined the future of your
of your life none of that is true that
your tribal affinity that your your
membership in a particular racial clan
that that determines how you will be
treated and how the rest of your life is
laid out for you none of that is true
that your choices are not your own once
you believe your choices are not your
own you end up justifying all sorts of
evil behavior once you believe that
choices cannot be freely made in
contravention of biology and tribal
affinity it's very difficult to have a
functioning Republic and this is why in
the end now I have an entire book coming
out about the subject the bargain
between Jerusalem and Athens between
religion and reason is deeply necessary
talk about more of this in just a second
so I have a new book coming out it's
called the right side of history it
comes out in a couple of weeks and the
central contention that the book makes
is that all of human life is based on a
certain number of premises that we have
to assume that all of Western
civilization is based on certain things
that we take for granted and many of
those things that we take for granted
are things that we actually get from
religious premises so we all take for
granted
Greek reason right the idea that we can
reason our way in and out of problems
science is is it outgrowth of this
belief in human reason and our capacity
to reason but even that capacity for
reason is based on even deeper roots
that capacity for reason is based on the
idea that you are a free individual
capable of exercising a logic that
exists outside of you that you are a
free individual not completely bound
down by biology capable of making
choices that you are not just a cluster
of meat wandering
through the universe reacting to the
environment around you yeah there's a
famous philosopher named Baraka Spinoza
and Spinoza Benedict Spinoza he he
suggested that basically human beings
were a stone that had been cast by fate
and that we thought that we had willed
our own motion but basically we didn't
were just along for the ride
all of Western civilization is based on
the opposite of that the idea that you
do will your own action that you have
the capacity to will your own action and
in politics that you're in control of
the decisions that you make and that
your personal life you're in control of
the decisions that you make that
responsibility is the key to a fruitful
exchange that you can't reason with
people who don't believe they're
responsible for their own actions that
reason itself is undermined by the
belief that human beings are not freely
capable of making choices now that is
that is the the conundrum we find
ourself in we've made excuses for
ourselves as a society blaming all of
our activities on outside forces or
internal forces but the freer you think
of yourself the more from the more you
think of yourself as a free actor acting
in a free country the more responsible
you're going to be the better you're
gonna be because the more responsible
you are for your own actions
right now we have a society that is
dedicated to removing responsibility
from people and then simultaneously in
in fits and starts we will try to
restore responsibility for certain
people we'll try to go back and fill in
the gaps and explain why Michael Jackson
should be abhorred even though we've
under we've undercut a lot of the
rationale for abhorrent Michael Jackson
Michael Jackson should be abhorred he
participated in evil activity who's a
free adult one of the freest people on
earth given his his his wealth and his
fame and he chose to do evil things and
his biological urge was not enough to
excuse that and the same thing is true
for all of us living in the freest
country in the history of the world now
I'm not talking that we're all
pedophiles but we all make decisions on
a daily basis for which we are
responsible and looking to society or
looking to biological urges or lookin to
anything else to to blame for our own
behavior is a is a deep problem for a
civilization that hopes to continue
functioning if you want a democracy if
you want a republic you have to believe
that you are a free actor capable of
acting morally both of those elements
you are free you are capable of making
decisions and you're capable of
acting in a moral fashion now again I am
not saying that I'm not even talking
about which behavior is moral in which
behavior is immoral from a generic
secular sense because I think that we
can obviously make distinctions between
pedophilia and all other sorts of crime
or all other sorts of behavior with that
said the generalised point which is that
we're gonna have to stop pathologizing
evil that it can be true that you have a
pathology toward doing something bad but
that you still have the capacity to
overcome that is the essence of Western
civilization and that is being ripped
away from us the only reason we're even
having this conversation about whether
Michael Jackson should have been
basically treated as an ill person or as
an evil person is because we have lost
the capacity to see evil for what it is
choices freely made by human beings
capable of making those choices in
contravention of their own biology it
used to be that you'd be able to say yes
both yes both he's a sick person with a
dr tiller doing sick things and also
he's an adult capable of overcoming that
but once we decide that we're not in
control of our own actions it's very
difficult to make the case for Western
civilization for individualism it's very
difficult to make a case for human
rights frankly because human rates are
again are based on this idea that we are
each individuals created in the image of
God and that we have the capacity to
make decisions freely and of our own
will you want to restore a system where
people believe in in right and wrong and
where we are responsible for one another
and where we don't hurt each other we're
gonna have to go back to a system where
we assume that your decisions are your
own and not the product of some other
evolutionary force or some product of
some some other environmental force
beyond your control now again that's not
to say there aren't biological forces
driving us there are that sounds to say
there aren't environmental forces that
put pressures on us there are the
question is how we shape those
environmental forces to get them off our
back but the goal has to be shaping
those environmental forces to get them
off our back to maximize human freedom
to maximize the human capacity because
that that right the rights the freedom
they come with duties you cannot have
duties without rights and you cannot
have rights without duties and we as a
society have decided to bifurcate the -
we want the rights without the duties or
we want the duties without the rights
you can't have it you can't have it both
ways
the right to the freedom comes with
responsibility not because we want you
to be responsible but because it simply
does you cannot be a free person if you
are incapable of making choices freedom
comes with your capacity and
responsibility to choose
alrighty meanwhile on a more sort of
political note the illegal immigration
surge at the border is continuing now
the media have finally decided to report
on an amazing how for two months they
said nothing about illegal immigration
surging at the border during the
government shutdown and while President
Trump was pushing Democrats to
compromise over immigration pretty
incredible but now they're reporting on
it so better late than never I suppose
the New York Times has a big piece today
called Border Patrol facilities put
detainees with medical conditions at
risk talking about the underfunding of
border patrol they point out that border
patrol simply does not have the
resources to deal with this massive
influx of migrants they say an average
of twenty 200 migrants a day are now
crossing the nation's 1,900 mile border
with Mexico many after grueling journeys
that leave them injured sick or badly
dehydrated yeah most of the nation's
Customs and Border Protection facilities
along the border lack sufficient
accommodations staffing or procedures to
thoroughly assess health needs or
provide more than basic emergency care a
situation that has led to dangerous
medical oversights I don't remember the
New York Times reporting this while the
entire Democratic Party talked about
disbanding ice and underfunding CBD I
don't remember that at all but now I
guess the media is catching on also the
media are reporting that a record number
of families are now crossing the border
this is according to the Washington Post
they're reporting that in February alone
US authorities detained more than 70
thousand migrants up from 58,000 in
January weird weird that they didn't
report any of this stuff until you know
after the government shutdown ends and
Trump declares a national emergency
how weird a once again showing that the
media the media's coverage of these
issues tends to have a rather large
impact on our public discourse okay
coming up in just a second I want to
talk about the Democrats and
intersectionality and their continued
push to avoid the consequences of their
own willingness to support anti-semitism
we're getting to that in just one second
first let's talk about life insurance
getting life insurance can feel like
assembling the world's worst jigsaw
puzzle it is confusing it takes forever
and when you're finally done it doesn't
look cool but if you have a mortgage
kids where anyone who depends on your
income it's a puzzle you need to solve
and policy genius can help you do it
policy genius is the easy way to get
life insurance in just two minutes you
can compare quotes from top insurers to
find the best policy for you when you
apply online the advisers at policy
genius will handle all the red tape
they'll even negotiate your rate with
the insurance company no commission
sales agents no hidden fees just helpful
advice and personalized service policy
genius doesn't just make life insurance
easy they also make it easy to find the
right home insurance auto insurance or
disability insurance they are
one-stop-shop for financial protection
so if you find life insurance puzzling
head on over to policy genius comm and
two minutes you can compare quotes find
the right policy and save up to 40%
doing it policy genius is indeed the
easy way to compare and buy life
insurance policy genius.com
be a responsible human being make sure
that you go take care of your family in
case god forbid something should happen
to you policy genius calm is the way to
make that happen again
comparequotes find the right policy in
two minutes save up to 40% policy
genius.com go check them out right now
okay
meanwhile the democrats are struggling
again with their anti-semitism their
willingness to - okay anti-semitism so
long as it comes from the intersectional
faces the real reason they're ok with
the sansei sematic nonsense the real
reason that they are now that they are
now backing out on condemning
anti-semitism is because they feel that
the people who are pushing the
anti-semitism are the most important
members of their party Nancy Pelosi just
went up against Johan Omar and Alexandra
Ocasio Cortez and Rasheeda Talib and
Nancy Pelosi came up on the losing end
that's an amazing thing now the reason
for that is the Nancy Pelosi was only
Speaker of the House by a couple of
votes in the last in the last speaker
vote all it would take is for a couple
of these Democrats to drop out and
suddenly she wouldn't be Speaker of the
House anymore so she knows where her
bread is buttered she can't afford to
alienate the radical wing of the
Democratic Party which now effectively
controls the Democratic Party also the
Democratic Party believes that their
pathway to victory lies not in pure
socialism but in a socialistic a
Democratic Socialist ik governmental
policy combined with racial appeals
overtly racial appeals who better to
push that than fresh face of the
Democratic Congress AOC so Alexander Oh
Cosmo Cortes for example she did an
interview with spectrum News
and she talked about the green New Deal
this is the kind of intersectional
socialism that Democrats are looking for
one of the things that some folks give
pushback is they're saying why are you
talking about racism when it comes to
the environment and they said racism has
nothing to do with environmentalism and
my immediate retort is look at Flint
look at Katrina look at Hurricane Maria
it's not as though income inequality or
social injustice or racism are these
separated out issues that you just
legislate to address those things and
fix you can't pass a lot to just end
income inequality you address it in
every issue every major systemic issue
okay so the basic appeal here is that
socialism may not be all that appealing
for minorities but if you overtly appeal
to minorities with socialism then maybe
you'll be okay the Democratic Party
wants to embrace this they are into
embracing this this is the new coalition
one of the people who is pushing that
idea is a center-left
democratic economist named Brad DeLong
he gave an interview to Vox in which
DeLong argues this is according to Greg
sergeant's at the Washington Post that
it's time for centrist like him to make
peace with the left the idea is that he
has to make peace with the open
socialist like AOC because they're going
to be the winning coalition that allow
the neoliberals
to sort of drive the boat that if Nancy
Pelosi can make peace with aoc if Nancy
Pelosi can make peace with al hen Omar
then they can create a coalition that is
durable and allows them to get done what
they need to get done they can it's
easier in other words to sort of hold
back a OC and Rasheeda Talib and Ilhan
Omar than it is to make peace with
people on the right and so you make
peace with the people on the Left
including the open anti-semites and the
people who cover for them this is the
basic notion that many on the Left have
been embracing the long notes that on
one issue from another from health care
to climate change centrist minded
Democrats have modulated the party's
priorities in hopes of striking a
political deal with the center-right but
that deal has never been forthcoming
because there's no functional center
right in US politics in other words so
long says we can't make a deal with
moderate Republicans there are no
moderate Republicans let's make a deal
with our hard left now Republicans and
conservatives would see this in the
opposite way they would say listen you
guys on the Left you moved radically
left in the last ten years and we can't
make a deal with you because
radically left in the last ten years and
then castigated us as racist bigots
sexist and homophobes but according to
the left they now have to make according
to sort of the mainstream Democratic
Party easier for Nancy Pelosi to kowtow
to bow down to bow the knee before AOC
then for Nancy Pelosi to create some
sort of centrist coalition now the
problem for Democrats is gonna come when
it turns out that a OSI is driving the
boat into an iceberg when it turns out
that the American people are not all
that fond of ALCS Genda Nancy Pelosi is
sort of hoping to have it both ways
use AOC to gin up the base and then when
it comes time for a national election
then you appeal to the center of the
country but the base is out of her
control and that is what the last week
and a half approved the last week and a
half approved that the base is not in
Nancy Pelosi's control and that even the
most vile elements of the Democratic
base will be bowed to by Nancy Pelosi
it's truly incredible so for example
you'll recall that L hen Omar is a
vicious anti-semite who's been using
anti Semitic language for years on end
she has anti-semitic views about Israel
she really doesn't believe that Israel
ought to exist
she doesn't which by the way isn't
anti-semitic view if you disagree with
policies of Israel then that is one
thing I disagree with many policies of
Israel I've discussed some of them on
the program but if you believe that
Israel does not have the right to exist
as a Jewish state but every Muslim
country has a right to exist as a Muslim
state if you believe that the only
Jewish state on planet earth does not
have a right to exist then you are in
fact engaging in anti-semitism in the
State Department even says as much this
is the perspective of rashida to leave
it's the perspective of Ilhan omar and
it is probably the perspective of aoc
who makes overtures to rashida to leave
and ohon omar and by the way makes
overtures also to people who are
apparently open terrorist supporters not
just jeremy corbyn of the Labour Party
who aoc paid homage to just a couple of
weeks ago but also she just retweeted
Youssef Munir who's the head of a
Palestinian rights organisation who also
happens to be a terror organization
sympathizer is according to The
Jerusalem Post in a tweet first
discovered by the investigative project
on terrorism Ocasio Cortes wrote quote
this is disappointing to see just last
week there was all this hubbub over an
untrue mischaracterization that I was
threatening primaries based on pro-ice
votes yet there seems to be no prob
at all with a zero tolerance stands for
simply asking about u.s. foreign policy
she did that in retweeting and
responding to a tweet by Yousef moon AR
the executive director of the u.s.
Center for Palestinian rights in his
tweet he wrote AIPAC activist tells New
York Times the lobby is coming for
congresswoman AOC Rashida to leave in
Ilhan Omar okay and and she is
retweeting this guy well moon Eyre has
condoned the efforts of the Popular
Front for the Liberation of Palestine an
actual terror group on his Twitter feed
before including retweeting a PFLP
announcement of a terror attack in
Jerusalem on June 16 2017 in another
tweet from July 2014
Minaya reminded his followers that the
military wings of PFLP and other
terrorist organizations not just Hamas
are all fighting against Israel in this
war the AOC has no problem tweeting that
out no it is it is hilarious to watch as
everybody on the Left points out every
time Steve King retweets a white
nationalist which he does far too often
and it's gross you know what happened to
Steve King for doing all that stuff he
lost his committee assignments AOC is
retweeting terrorist sympathizers no
problem the the left is is caving in to
all of this because I'm gonna tell you I
mean the the process of the Cavin was
truly astonishing I'll explain it in
just a second first you're gonna have to
go over to Daley we're now calm and
subscribe for $9.99 a month you can get
a subscription to daily wire when you do
you get the rest of this show live you
also get an additional two hours of the
show every afternoon so many things that
we talk about in the afternoon that
you're missing if you're not a
subscriber and you get a commercial free
Plus for $99 a year you get the very
greatest in beverage vessels you leftist
here's how to cold tumble or view it
push it cast her eyes upon it it is
magnificent go check that out right now
later today you know among the among the
many glories of our additional two hours
we're having on zubi who is a rapper and
destroyer of the British women's
deadlift record while identifying his
woman we'll have him on to discuss his
massive his massive show of strength as
a powerful proud woman we'll discuss it
with him also you should check us out
and subscribe because we have great
Sunday specials like Arthur Brooks when
you subscribe you get that on Saturday
Arthur Brooks the head of American
Enterprise Institute and author of the
new book love your enemies he joined us
on the Sunday special here's what it
sounded like I'm Arthur Brooks I'm
president of the American Enterprise
Institute and I have a great pleasure of
being on ben shapiro
sundays special where we talk about
politics and we talk about love and we
talk about happiness and we talk about
his new book which is coming out March
19th and we talk about my book love your
enemies which comes out on March 12
don't miss it
so go check all of that out also leave
us a review over at YouTube or iTunes we
always appreciate it helps us with the
rankings we're the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast in the
nation
[Music]
so the Democrats have cut this devil's
bargain with the anti-semites in their
base I mean it is it is that simple and
it's the same Democrats who have
criticized president Trump rightly for
cow telling and winking and nodding at
the alright in 2016 it was correct that
it was gross for Trump to do that in
2016 I criticized it at the time it was
disgusting
I have criticized Benjamin Netanyahu the
Prime Minister of Israel for making
common ha common cause with the cojones
and he has now brought into his
coalition members of the former party of
mayor Kahana who are legitimately
extremists who have celebrated terrorist
incidents like the Barack Goldstein
Massacre right Netanyahu brought them
into his coalition that's disgusting he
should never have done that it's really
gross hey the Democrats are doing the
exact same thing right now
the Democrats are bringing into their
coalition and championing and putting
them on the cover of Rolling Stone
people who are in favor of terrorist
groups or at least have spoken out in
defense of terrorist groups
remember Ilhan Omar actually voted
against she voted against a proposal
that would have punished Isis members
more harshly
she has encouraged Isis members in
Minnesota not to be treated with great
harshness by the law actually wrote an
appeal on behalf of I believe a former
Isis member to a Minnesota judge she has
laughed and joked about Hamas and
Hezbollah they've hobnob with Linda
Sarsour who's an active terrorist
supporter I mean she's she's an actual
supporter of terrorists before or at
least prior terrorists Linda stars who
are speaking out by the way against
Nancy Pelosi
she's a noted anti-semite with strong
ties to the Nation of Islam and Louis
Farrakhan Sarsour posts posted comments
in a facebook missive against Nancy
Pelosi
she said Nancy is a typical white
feminist upholding the patriarchy doing
the dirty work of powerful white men god
forbid the men are upset no worries
Nancy to the rescue to stroke their egos
so Linda Sarsour and AOC and Rashidah
Talib and Ilhan Omar these are the new
leaders of the Democratic Party and
Nancy Pelosi is just hanging on for dear
life hoping that she can control the
alligator a little bit that's all she's
hoping she's riding the back of this
alligator hoping that it eats her last
it will not eat her last by the way so
what exactly are the Democrats doing
about the open anti-semitism inside
their own party here's how this works so
in the last couple of days there were
calls for Democrats to censure
Rashidah Talib I would not not Rashid to
leave Ilhan Omar sin for them to put out
a congressional resolution naming Ilhan
Omar because of her three prior
anti-semitic comments in six weeks
instead Democrat said you know what
we'll do we'll put out a generic
resolution a generic resolution that
condemns anti-semitism just generally
which of course is a way of avoiding the
actual reason why the resolution is
being put forth in the first place it's
like putting forth a resolution on the
evils of white nationalism without
mentioning Steve King right after Steve
King's comments like we all know why
we're doing this don't we but that was
too much that was too much the base of
the Democratic Party they decided we
can't do that even the CBC protested
Ilhan Omar protested AOC protested so
then the Democrats decided you know
we're gonna have to table this thing
Johan Omar's name won't go in it but now
now we are going to change the language
of the bill to include resident language
condemning anti-muslim abayas now listen
you ought to pass another resolution
condemning anti-muslim bias based on you
know like an inciting incident go for it
but this entire incident was based on
Ilhan Omar being an anti-semite so ill
Hannah Mars an anti-semite and then
presumably some people react to Ilhan
Omar with Islamophobia not members of
Congress because you can't name any who
have done that but some randos in West
Virginia and so we get a congressional
resolution condemning both anti-semitism
and Islamophobia without mentioning L
hen Omar the inciting reason for this
entire incident its absurdity on its
face and it is a way of watering this
down so it doesn't look like a
condemnation of Ilhan Omar it looks like
a defense of Ilhan Omar the Democratic
Party is doing this because they know
where their bread is buttered
Ilhan Omar butters their bread AOC
butters their bread Rasheeda Talib
butters their bread this is the decision
that they have made and you can tell
this from leading members of the
Democratic coalition so eliot engel is a
Jewish Congress person from New York he
had condemned
Ilhan Omar's comments as anti-semitic
because they are in fact anti-semitic
then he was asked should L hen Omar be
stripped of her Foreign Affairs
Committee assignment first of all
there's no reason she should be on
foreign affairs anyway it's a very
prestigious committee assignment she
knows nothing about foreign policy her
foreign policy positions are absurd on
their face she's in favor of Nicolas
Maduro basically remaining as the
dictator of Venezuela I mean she is
she's in a dangerous ignoramus and
Elliot
won't even say that you should be ousted
from Foreign Affairs you're the chairman
of a really important committee right
Foreign Affairs your this is the center
of a lot and it's certainly the center
of this discussion about Israel at what
point do you say to her congressman Omar
look you're not on this committee
anymore you strip her of your seat are
you close to that or at that point no I
I'm not close to it I first of all it's
not up to me this is done by the the
leadership I don't know that that would
do anything except exacerbate the
situation even more I'm looking to get
rid of anti-semitism not looking to
punish anybody ah you're gonna have to
explain representative angle how you get
rid of anti-semitism without punishing
anti-semites you're gonna have to
explain how that works
then this this really pathetic patting
Johan Omar on the head Johan Omar is how
old forty years old I believe huh no
mark when was she born let's see
Omaha Omar age she is 37 years old she
is two years older than I am she is
twice married she was a fellow at the
University of Minnesota she is not an
ignoramus she is not stupid
she is not a fool and yet the Democrats
because they don't want to acknowledge
that they are okaying anti-semitism in
their own ranks have decided basically
you know what it turns out that she's
just a she's a poor ignorant woman who
doesn't know anything if anybody ever
said that about
Ilhan Omar on the other side that she is
she's just ignorant of basic things
about about life and about anti-semitism
and about religious bigotry you know
because she's an ignoramus then they'd
immediately be accused of taking of not
taking her seriously enough
but I think she's ignorant because I
think that she's ignorant about
Venezuela like I don't think she knows
things about Venezuela but she's
certainly not ignorant about
anti-semitism for years members of the
Minnesota Jewish community have been
approaching Ilhan Omar reported by the
Minneapolis star-tribune
and talking her about anti-semitism and
she has not cared one iota this is what
she believes the Democratic Party has
made its peace with the radicals in
their base they've they're quickly
becoming the UK Labour Party in a second
we're gonna talk about how the media
continues to cover for this because it's
quite insane so dana Milbank is a
columnist over at the washington post
now The Washington Post has been awful
about all of this
The Washington Post has run a bevy of
pieces in full full-throated defense of
aloha Nomar why because the Washington
Post are the Democratic leadership
they're the same and so they have to
pretend that ohon omar isn't an
anti-semite in fact she's speaking the
truth dana Milbank was asked about was
asked specifically about the democratic
treatment of Ilhan omar he said listen
it's pretty obvious the democrats hold
themselves to a higher standard with
regard to al hahn Omar uh-huh sure the
Democrats are holding her to a higher
standard than Republicans have been
holding themselves I think that's
probably also true on me too and other
things the question is should Democrats
do the same thing Republicans have been
doing sort of circled the wagons and
basically look the other way because
there are a member of the tribe and I
and I think that it's probably
worthwhile to hold yourself to a higher
standard okay there is no higher
standard again they took an original
resolution that would have included a
condemnation of Ilhan Omar they stripped
out her name and then they added anti
Islam sentiment to an actual resolution
about anti-semitism which is astonishing
it's astonishing and yet we're being
told by the media they hold themselves
to a higher standard yeah sure right
uh-huh
I don't remember Steve King being
featured on the cover of Rolling Stone
with speaker Paul Ryan by the way like I
don't remember that happening pretty
amazing stuff okay meanwhile one of the
great irritants for Republicans at this
point has to be the fact that well
Democrats are running as far as they can
to the left Republicans seem to be
following them to the left
apparently Republicans are now advancing
paid leave now I understand that there
are some lawmakers on the right who are
big fans of paid parental leave and that
includes senators with whom I am very
friendly the bills would supposedly
provide a government-backed paid
parental leave from from now spurred in
part by activism from Ivanka Trump
according to roll call a growing number
of Republicans have embraced arguments
that would improve maternal and fetal
health provide income stability for
families and strength and caregivers
connection to the work force paid family
leave would allow the GOP to showcase
its claim to uphold family values while
still appealing to working-class voters
whose sense of economic instability
helped propel Trump to victory in 2016
now forcing businesses to either pay for
pay
family leave are forcing taxpayers to
take on the burden of paid family leave
is obviously a new government
entitlement Republicans are pushing this
at the same time that the debt is being
blown out I'm old enough to remember
when Republicans pretended to care about
the debt I'm old enough to remember when
conservatives pretended to care about
the deficit but the US budget deficit
according to Bloomberg has now widened
to three hundred and ten billion dollars
in the first four months of the fiscal
year underscoring according to Bloomberg
the revenue hid from Republican tax cuts
and an increase in government spending
it ain't about the tax cuts gang it's
about the spending the budget gap widens
seventy seven percent why or receipts
fell by two percents 1.1 trillion
dollars that seems like a solid amount
of money to take in does it not but
spending rose nine percent to one point
four trillion dollars so the budget did
receive a tiny bump in customs duties
about twenty five billion dollars but
the US trade gap widened which by the
way shows that that president Trump's
trade policy is economically ignorant
the economy has continued to boom
because the trade deficit is not a good
indicator of whether an economy is
booming or not the trade deficit usually
means that people in America can afford
foreign products so we are buying them
also President Trump actually
exacerbated the trade deficit made it
worse why because by pushing the idea
that tariffs were going to clamp in at
the beginning of 2019 he forced a bunch
of businesses to buy products early from
foreign countries so it actually
accelerated the trade deficit with all
of that said it would be really nice if
Republicans would not be Democrats we
already have Democrats we don't need
another Democratic Party okay meanwhile
I feel like I really need to comment on
a great exchange that happened yesterday
on Joe Rogan's podcast for those who
don't know Joe Rogan's podcast you
should give it a listen
it's really a lot of fun Joe's a great
question so Joe and Tim Poole who is one
of his sidekicks
Joe and Tim Poole were questioning some
members of the Twitter clan so Jack
Dorsey showed up on Joe Rogan's podcast
and Joe Rogan asked him the hard
question he asked him why isn't the band
some people but not other people in
Twitter had no answer whatsoever
we have a divide between the
conservative estimation of what's
happening and then the definition that's
the liberal definition of it I think
that's right Joe and I think what I'm
trying to say is that it's not that you
can't have those viewpoints
it's a if you're taking those viewpoints
and you're targeting about them out of
specific person in a way that reflects
your intent to abuse and harass them
what if it's in the context of the
conversation what if she saying that I
don't think that trans women should be
allowed in these female spaces to make
decisions for women and then this
person's arguing and she says a woman is
biologically female you are never going
to be a woman she responded with men
aren't women though and that was her
first in the series of events that's
what got her the suspension in the
morning that was one of many tweets that
were part of providing context it was
not okay via the woman who speaking is
Vijaya Gaddy who is the company's global
lead for legal policy and Trust and
safety and that's Joe Rogan asking
specifically about Megan Murphy who's
been a guest on our show Megan Murphy of
course is a feminist she's a left-wing
feminist who was banned from Twitter for
making the absolutely obvious contention
that men are not women and women are not
men Twitter claimed that this was
targeting of particularly transgender
people and Joe Rogan and Tim Poole are
pointing out how dumb this is that
twitter has no consistent standard but
again Twitter doesn't have to have a
consistent standards they have market
dominance it's pretty astonishing how
the left will continue to shut down
debate with no good excuse for doing so
simply because their confirmation bias
is so incredibly strong when you have an
agenda it allows you to run roughshod it
really does allow you to run roughshod
over your own supposed central
principles you can tell where people's
real principles lie by where by which
principles people are willing to violate
in pursuit of those primary principles
so Twitter says it's a free speech
platform a place for people to speak out
and debate but their real priority is
not that their real priority is social
leftism
and when the two come into conflict
social leftism overrules anything having
to do with free speech good on Joe Rogan
and Tim Poole for exposing the insane
hypocrisy and stupidity of the of the
Twitter the Twitter leadership alrighty
time for some things I like and then
some things that I hate so things that I
like there is a movie that is now
available on Amazon Prime it's called
you were never really here it's sort of
a newfangled take on taxi driver frankly
I think it's a better movie than taxi
driver that's with Joaquin Phoenix who
is in fact our finest living actor the
only other competitor would probably be
Daniel day-lewis but he is retired
Joaquin Phoenix
turns in another fantastic performance
when you talk about people who just
inhabit a role or you don't even think
of them as an actor they're just the
role Joaquin Phoenix is the guy the
basic plot is essentially taxi driver he
is a he is the kind of taxi driver he is
basically a veteran who has had some bad
experience as a suicidal veteran and he
has hired by a by a middleman to go save
this this state legislators daughter
from sex slavery and let's just say
nothing good in Sue's questions
man call any wants to see you right away
state senator Albert Votto his teenage
daughters missing
must leave he got an anonymous text with
an address I've heard of these places I
said you were brutal so he he did win
the the best Best Actor did Joaquin
Phoenix for his role in this he's
terrific actor honestly it gives me hope
for the Joker movie so the new Joker
movie is gonna be directed by Scorsese
correct and Joaquin Phoenix plays the
Joker that is fantastic casting so
looking forward to that the movie is
very brutal it is definitely rated R you
were never really here available on
Amazon Prime okay time for some things
that I hate so let's talk a little bit
about HR 1 HR 1 is the Nancy Pelosi led
houses first priority and basically it
restructures voting and voter ID all
across the country in violation of
federalism states are generally supposed
to set the standards and state
redistricting is supposed to set the
standards for how voting is done on the
state level HR 1 according to the
Heritage Foundation seizes the authority
of states to regulate voter registration
and the voting process by forcing states
to implement early voting automatic
voter registration same-day registration
online voter registration and no-fault
absentee ballots a balloting all of
which are the devil's playground for
voter fraud
early voting first of all should not be
allowed except in really bad
circumstances or unless you're a member
of the military or something early
voting is bad because a lot of news
breaks right before an election second
automatic voter registration you should
not be automatically registered to vote
because maybe you don't want to vote
same-day registration is absurd it
doesn't allow you to actually check
whether the person is who they say they
are online voter registration is very
difficult to control no-fault absentee
balancing again that's that's a problem
because people vote absentee instead of
simply going down to their polling place
makes it more difficult to verify their
vote this creates a lot more chaos at
the polls which is exactly the opposite
of what we need it'll hurt voter turnout
because everybody will early vote it
will degrade the accuracy of
registration lists by automatically
registering individuals from state
databases such as DMV and well
our offices in California you can have a
driver's license if you're an illegal
immigrant so if you automatically are
registered from the state database well
that's going to be a problem isn't it it
constitutes a recipe according to
heritage correctly for massive voter
registration fraud by hackers and cyber
criminals through online voter
registration it's hilarious to watch as
the left tries to loosen the methods of
of confirming who voters are at the same
time that they are trying to make sure
that only people who see Captain Marvel
can review Captain Marvel this is a
point made by one of our producers here
by a head of production Jonathan Haidt
to me the other day he was pointing out
that now Rotten Tomatoes has changed
their standards on who gets to review
Captain Marvel you can only do it if you
have bought a ticket to Captain Marvel
they've changed the standard why because
they were afraid that fanboys were going
to crap all over Captain Marvel and
lower the viewer rating the generalized
viewer rating and so they've decided
they're essentially going to use a form
of voter ID so yes to voter ID for
seeing a movie and reviewing it on
Rotten Tomatoes no to voter ID for you
know actually voting this will
the effectiveness of state voter ID laws
by allowing individuals to vote without
an ID and sign a statement in which they
claim they are who they say they are but
you can just forge the signature
obviously it reduced the number of
Federal Election Commission members from
6 to 5 allowing the political party with
3 Commission seats to control the
Commission which of course means that if
Democrats take control of the FEC then
they will control the entire FEC it
would require States to restore the
ability of felons to vote the moment
they are out of prison which is a state
issue not a federal issue it would
violate the separation of powers even
the ACLU opposes HR 1 because it said
they say that it goes too far in a lot
of these directions so it's a pretty
extreme bill don't believe all the hype
when Democrats say they're restoring
voter integrity it is precisely the
opposite all righty well we will be back
here a little bit later to know two
additional hours which is why you
subscribe otherwise be here tomorrow
we'll be here for more i'm ben shapiro
this is the ben shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Adam sy
Yvette's audio is mixed by Mike Carmina
hair and makeup is by Joshua alvera
production assistant Nick Sheehan the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19